Let's take a step back and look at our scatter
plot between friend count and age. This scatter plot keeps
us really close to the data because we are visualizing
every point in the data set. In general, it's not possible
to judge important quantities from such a display. Sometimes you
want to understand how the mean or median of a variable.
Varies with another variable. That is it can be helpful
to summarize the relationship between two variables in other ways rather
than just always plotting every single point. For example we can
ask how does the average friend count vary over age. To
do this, we could start by creating a table that for
each age it gives us the mean and median for income.
To do this we're going to need to learn some new code.
To create the table, we're going to use the R package called
D Plyr. I'm going to install and load that package now.
The D Plyr package let's us split up a data frame and
apply a function to some parts of the data. Some
of the common functions you might use are filter, group
by, mutate and arrange. You can learn more about the
dplyr package and browse there some examples from the links and
the instructor notes. For now we'll work through an example
together. So the first thing that I want to do is that
I want to group my data frame by age. I'm going
to save this grouping in a new variable called age groups.
Next I want to summarize this new group in enough data And
create new variables of mean thread count, median friend count and
the number people in each group. So we're going to summarize our
variable that we just created, age groups. Now right after I enter
the data frame that I want to work on. I'm going to
enter the variables that I want to create. So I want
the friend count mean, and I get that by just taking
the mean of the variable friend count. And I want the friend
count median. And finally I want the number of users
in each group. This in function can only be used for
summarise, and it reports how many people are really in
each group. The last thing I want to do is save this
result into a new variable. I'll use the same dataframe
abbreviation, and then add FCbyAge, since we have friend count by
age. Running this code, I can see that I get a
new dataframe with 101 observations, or groups, and four different variables.
Using the head command, I can print out the first couple
rows to examine the data from. So notice, I have age,
friend count mean, friend count median, and n, the number of
users in each group. Now the state of frame isn't in any
order. So I'm going to rearrange my data frame so that way
the ages go from lowest to high. I'll just use the arrange
function on the current data frame and arrange it by age.
I'll save the result over the variable I just had and now
heading out the data frame I can see that I have everything in
order. Now this may seem like a lot of codes, so I really
encourage you to take your time and to review the code and the
example. Make sure that you know what each piece is doing. So that
way you can write this code on your own. The two things that
I really want to point out is that we need to pass in a
data frame, or a grouping, at the beginning of each function. We also
need to save the result into a new variable, and we pass that
into the next function. This is what makes it difficult
to understand this code at first, so I'm going to show you
one other way to get this same table. To start, we're
just going to take our data set and apply some function to
it. To do that, I'm going to use the percent period percent
symbol. This allows me to chain functions onto our data set.
So I'm going to perform one function at a time. One after
another on pf. The first thing I'll do is group my
data set by age. Now I'm going to chain on one
more function. I'm going to summarize the result using friend count mean.
Friend count median, and an. And finally, I'll add one
more function, using this chain command, the percent period percent, and
this time I'll arrange my data frame, by age. All
of this code will produce, this exact data frame, so I
want to make sure I save it to a variable.
I'll save it to pf, friend count by age, and I'll
head the data frame just like before so that way
we can check our result. Running this code, we see that
we get the same exact result, we have age, friend
count mean, friend count median, and, and the number of users
in each age group. Printing out more rows, we can
carefully scrutinize the table to learn about the relationship between age
and friend count. We can already notice that on average. Users
who are age 13 have slightly lower friend counts than those
who are 14. It also looks like the mean friend
count peaks at age 16 and age 17. Now, of course,
we don't want to be summarizing and digging through tables
like this. This is very tedious. We could show these observations
more effectively with a visualization. So let's plot this table
of averages. This is going to be your next programming assignment.
I want you to plot the average friend count versus
age. Make sure that you use the the appropriate data set.
We're using this new data set here that we
just created. And be sure that you have the appropriate
variable names. They're different from before. Create your plot
in RStudio and then check your work with ours.